il adore sauter des dessins il ya les
pinceaux et les pots de peinture des
outils virtuels pour créer son propre
personnage de dessin animé ce matin ces
jeunes plaisir waeles leur créativité
s'exprimer sur tablettes tactiles argué
pots de peinture c'est très intéressant
parce que l'on peut fermer toi et moi je
lui ferai des gens mais voilà ils vont
dessiner les personnages et les décors
et jc les films énormément en plus sur
ces incidents qui ont dû refaire bref un
peu touché à tout pour voir si on peut
voir arriver à faire des plats cet
apport de films et d'animations pour
cette initiation express l'animatrice de
l'atelier leur a donné trois mois pour
les aider à construire leur histoire
elle va compter dans ceux là ont la même
forme a pris 10 les sourires taille au
départ et ça est un jour important
à part lui chance à fait surpris d'avoir
des personnages décolore un jeu ludique
aussi éveiller les enfants à la
diversité sur des thématiques avec le
soleil qui me touchent moi aussi et je
vais transmettre aux enfants pour voir
une autre édition créer son dessin animé
s'avère facile sur un outil
qu'évidemment il maîtrise parfaitement
sachez pour les couleurs et pour défiler
jusqu'à mettre le doigt sur l'écran une
fois les dessins terminer l'histoire
imaginée le logiciel alim le tout et
personnages prennent vie
[Musique]